bueno esta es precisamente parte de los
retos que enfrenta el gobierno de
gustavo petro porque es 'plan pistola'
significa una tensión significa un reto
de estas organizaciones
precisamente al gobierno entrante y le
muestran que tienen un determinado
control en algunos territorios del país
bastante amplios e importantes y los
anuncios que se han dado hasta ahora de
paz total no han desmenuzado digamos o
detallado un poco la metodología la
manera en que se podría desarrollar una
eventual proceso de acogimiento de estos
grupos por eso el reto está en la
implementación estamos en la fase del
discurso de la posesión y en el gran
reto que es el de la implementación cual
podría ser uno de los grandes obstáculos
de todo este proceso en el tema de la
paz total viene por supuesto la
negociación con diferentes actores muy
distintos
significa una aproximación al ln a las
disidencias de las farc donde hay un
marco de referencia muy importante
es el acuerdo de paz de alcanzado con
las farc y otro es el camino y el
proceso que pueda darse con estos grupos
ilegales del clan del golfo y otras
organizaciones
narcotraficantes con ellos va a ser
difícil encontrar un punto en el que
haya reducción de penas posiblemente
donde se tenga que discutir el tema de
los activos donde se tenga que discutir
el proceso de sometimiento va va a tener
que surtirse un diálogo y una
negociación muy detallada antes de
lograr materializarse un acuerdo con
ellos